- On this episode, we talk about
going out of business.
(rap music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
(rap music)
Everybody, this
is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 96
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hope everybody had a
wonderful Mother's Day.
Hope you enjoyed that,
hope you had the wonderful
weather we had in New York City
that was very nice, very warm yesterday.
A little grumpy this morning.
DRock's team this morning beat my team
three out of four times in basketball.
Nothing to do with DRock, but, you know,
but they won anyway.
Oh, anyway, episode 100
of the #AskGaryVee Show
is a week from today.
It looks like we are going to be doing it
at the Gansevoort Hotel.
We will update later today.
I'm not sure when this
is airing in return,
but by tomorrow that will be firmed up.
But pretty sure it's going to be
in the Gansevoort Hotel on Park Avenue.
We'll get all those updates
on a Facebook reminder,
we'll blast that out on
the Gary VIP email list,
we'll link it up on tomorrow's
episode of #AskGaryVee.
Everybody listening on the podcast,
you can check out on Facebook,
I'll probably send out a
link on Twitter as well.
There may be a limit,
so we need to talk about that.
Also, after I'm done taping,
I know a lot of Vayniac's,
VaynerNation coming,
I'd like them to hang out with each other.
I've got to go to a business
meeting at Citi Field,
a Mets game.
It's in the back of my mind
to maybe come back in the city
10:30 to 11:30 and maybe
do a drink up somewhere.
Keep that in the back of your mind,
because I know notice a lot of people,
Toronto's coming.
As a matter of fact, if you're coming,
please in the Facebook
and the Youtube sections
tell me where you're coming from.
Seems like a lot of people are
very localized, makes sense.
But some people are making the schlep.
And the schlep excites me.
India, let's get into the show.
- Hey.
- [Voiceover] Jared asks,
" I have an app idea,
with my target market
"willing to test it.
"But I need to create an app
and I'm not a programmer.
"Any advice?"
- Jared, this question pisses me off
because I'm asked this all the time.
I probably get about 30,
40 of these emails a week.
I'm not sure if you're
trying to get on the show,
or if you really mean it.
This seems like the simplest
thing to do in the world.
I mean, Meetup.com has 800
different developer meet ups.
And if you want it bad enough,
you go to the closest one,
even if it's 75 miles away.
There's just 8,000 communities
of developers out there.
Literally, when I get an
email from somebody saying,
"Hey, Gary, I've got the next big idea,
but I need a developer,"
literally, immediately I go like this.
I read it.
I'm checking my...let's reenact it.
Oh, let me just catch up on my,
DRock I'll do that later,
let me just read.
Oh, let me check some emails.
Hey Gary, love the show,
you're the best person I've ever met.
Oh, by the way, I've got a big time idea
except I need a developer.
Out of (bleep) business.
If you are not capable,
if you're not capable of finding your
business partner developer,
then how in the world are
you going to win in business?
Ideas are shit, execution's
the game, let's move on.
- [India] From Shady Giorgio.
- Shady.
What up, baby?
It's Shady, India.
You're into Shady, right?
By name only, go ahead.
[Voiceover] Shady asks,
"What are bad habits you had and overcame,
"and how did overcoming
them aid your growth
"as an entrepreneur?"
- Shady, good question.
Not like the last one.
I think the things I
overcame were big eyes.
Which was, hey I'm gonna
do a lot of things at once.
Actually, I don't know
if I've overcome it.
I've gotten a little bit better.
Definitely in this chapter
of building VaynerMedia
I've overcome that issue,
I've been really focused
as CEO of VaynerMedia,
and general partner of Vayner/RSE.
So, I've been really focused.
And so, big eyes.
Just trying to do too many things at once.
And what that's allowed
me to do is be successful
and build another big business
instead of half-pregnant across the board.
I think the other thing that I've overcome
is I've started,
and I'm still not great at this either,
these are always works in progress
when it's not the thing that
comes most natural to you,
but I think what I've
been doing well lately
is I've been giving more honest, critical,
direct to people's face feedback.
You know, I tend to be a little bit soft,
I'm much more of a honey over vinegar guy.
Between our former manager
and director Kelly and AJ,
very straight-shooter operators,
they've moved me along.
I've definitely evolved in that category.
I'm definitely better at it.
I still want to deal with a ton of empathy
and heart and soul,
but shooting it straight is
bringing more value to me
and it's just speeding up
the process of victory.
You can't have a CEO,
I wouldn't say I'm not,
I'm very decisive,
but boy, delivering bad news
does not come natural to me
and I don't love it.
Building infrastructure around me
and then doing it myself
has been an important
evolution that I've done
much better at VaynerMedia
than I've done at Wine Library,
and what that's given me is a thing that
a lot of you know that I value
which is speed.
Those two.
- [Voiceover] Christopher asks,
"Gary, how can I prevent angel investors
"interested in investing in my enterprise
"from potentially stealing our IP?"
- Christopher, this is
a really interesting
Monday morning show.
Christopher, this is also a shit question.
Ideas are shit, execution's the game.
People walk around going,
"Gary, please sign this NDA
before I pitch you my idea
as an angel investor."
Let me reenact it.
India, I'll get to that later,
let me just catch up on my email.
"Hey, Gary, I'm a really big fan
and you're the best guy I've ever met.
Anyway, listen I've
got this big time idea.
But before I pitch it to you,
please see the following attachment
and sign the NDA because I
just can't let you see it.
I don't want it stolen."
Great, delete.
Out of (bleep) business.
If you literally think
in 2015 that your idea
is so profound that
nobody's ever thought of it,
that when I sit with you and I pitch
I go, you're a dope, but
I'm gonna take this idea
and give it to somebody else,
you are lost in the
reality of the marketplace.
Again, if that is where
your mindset is at,
I just don't see that as a winning mindset
for 2015 and beyond.
The days of patent or idea IP,
every idea has been thought about.
There is nobody who has come
up with a big time idea.
I'm telling you, every idea
has been thought about.
All of them, every one of them.
People executing,
or having the pieces in
place to be able to execute,
or the right time in their career,
the right resources financially,
energy, skills, opportunities,
those are the variables.
Not the ideas.
This is a nasty show.
What's that?
I know.
We've got straight up.
What is this episode 96?
This is nasty.
96 is nasty, VaynerNation.
- [India] From Steve McDermott.
- Steve.
- [Voiceover] Our very own Steve asks,
"Which marketing vehicles are working best
"to grow the businesses of the startups
"you've invested in?"
- Steve, a hardcore
VaynerMedia employee
working on data and insights.
I wonder if this is a
hedged question or not.
But, Steve, the answer to
this question is clearly
Facebook dark posts.
I've pounded this over and over.
It's funny,
the VaynerMedia clients don't
recognize what's going on.
All my investment companies
are only playing in this space.
You know, I'm going to look
it up right now in real time.
I'm gonna predict, right here on the spot,
that Wish, the app Wish, the shopping app,
is probably in the top
150 in the app store.
This is a company, met the
founder at Cannes last year,
the big advertising festival.
Just go through this Facebook.
Facebook, by the way,
Dub Mash I missed it.
I skyped with the founder
of Dub Mash from Berlin
like seven weeks ago, so on it.
10, 15 weeks ago I screwed it up.
Snapchat, okay.
This is what I do all the time by the way,
DRock you can focus here.
Every so often,
actually I didn't do it this morning,
it's just fun to do it,
I'm just always looking
at the top 100 apps
to basically get a feel.
Usually where I'm most excited
about is down here, right?
Because the top is pretty consistent.
But has anything popped up here,
like Wallapop, like those kind of things,
I'm always trying to see.
Let me just see if Wish is here,
It's somewhere, here it is, 112.
Zoom in, baby.
- [DRock] Yep.
- 112.
All Facebook dark posts.
And I mean all Facebook dark posts.
If people understood what
was going on arbitrage-wise
on Facebook dark posts right now,
which is a slang term.
Facebook advertising
platform where you can
reach anybody that you want.
If people understood that,
they would win every single time.
Just like Google ad
words in the early 2000s
that Amazon and Ebay used
to build their businesses.
Still can't believe
people don't understand
this is what happened.
Facebook is absolutely the place that
you can't milk enough
of that cow right now.
And again, over the next 24 to 48 months
it will disappear,
and it will more or less level out
and become appropriate.
Right now it's underpriced.
In four years, I'll still love it,
intuitively I believe,
but it's gonna be appropriate.
I'll be like, this is worth it.
Just exactly worth it,
not this is worth eight bucks
and I'm paying a dollar for it.
So, Facebook dark posts.
If my startups could
spend every penny they had
they would on that place.
Pinterest starting to
emerge a little bit as well.
- [India] Do you want this one
to make up for the shitty one?
- No.
I want those shit ones to sit.
- [India] Okay.
- [Voiceover] Amber asks,
"Hey Gary!
"What would you prioritize
as a one person business?"
- [India] Yeah, that's how I do it.
- Amber.
That's how you roll?
Ladies.
That was an L, I don't know.
You can see, that's
what got me the ladies.
(laughter)
Amber?
Amber, this is a great question,
and a very simple one
to be honest with you.
And I see, India just informed me about
the artistic side of
what you're pumping out.
And so this will be kind of
interesting of an answer,
but it's the truth.
If there is one thing I would focus on
as a solo-preneur, it is sales.
Money is oxygen.
And so, you know, you
could do anything you want.
You could produce the greatest art,
the greatest sneakers,
the greatest cup of coffee,
if you don't know how to sell it,
you are out of business.
Which tends to be the
theme of this episode.
So, I would highly recommend
you focus on sales.
You have to figure out
can you sell your thing.
Whatever that is,
it's a service, sell out the show,
your thing that you actually sell.
If you're not capable of
selling as a solo-preneur,
there's really nothing else that matters,
because money intake
is the way you continue
to the next move, right?
It's like up, up, down, down,
left, right, left, right,
B, A, B, A, select, start
powers up your lives in Contra,
you need lives.
And cash is that Nintendo
cheat sheet hack.
And so, that's what it is,
cash is oxygen.
Cash, say it with me VaynerNation,
cash is oxygen, cash is oxygen.
Cash is oxygen,
India, come on.
Cash, come on India, do it with me.
Cash, come on, India.
Cash is oxygen
- Cash is oxygen.
- Yes! Yes!
This is a very special episode.
Very special 96th episode
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
VaynerNation, question of the day,
cash is fill in the blank.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(rap music)